La ville d’Athènes est l’objet d’un
récit mythique.
Celui-ci ne s’attarde pas sur la manière
dont la ville a été bâtie, ce qui reste
très flou, mais plutôt sur la manière dont
elle acquiert un rôle spécial, un destin
pourrait-on dire.
Et ce destin, Athènes le porte dans son nom,
en effet, cela ne vous aura pas échappé
mais Athènes, c’est la ville d’Athéna,
déesse associée à la sagesse, l’éducation
mais aussi à la stratégie militaire.
Ce mythe est connu sous plusieurs versions,
mais il y a un point sur lequel elles s’accordent,
c’est le conflit qui oppose Athéna et Poséidon,
dieu des mers, pour le contrôle de l’Attique,
la région d’Athènes.
Rivalisant pour séduire les habitants, les
deux divinités auraient offert chacune un
présent censé illustrer l’intérêt de
se ranger sous leur protection.
Poséidon propose aux Athéniens un cheval,
animal indispensable de la vie antique, utilisé
pour les labours, les moulins et
la guerre.
Athéna offre pour sa part un olivier.
C’est sans doute moins impressionnant que
l’étalon noir de son concurrent, mais tout
bien considéré, il présente aussi de nombreux
avantages.
Il fournit évidemment l’huile, une denrée
essentielle et très prisée dont on peut faire commerce
ces rameaux symbolisent également
la paix, la stabilité.
Ce dilemme entre la fougue du cheval et la
sagesse de l’arbre est bien entendu tranché
en faveur de l’olivier.
Ceux qui se nomment désormais Athéniens
érigent alors un sanctuaire en l’honneur
de leur nouvelle déesse protectrice de la
ville.
L’essentiel du mythe s’est déroulé sur
l’Acropole, ce promontoire qui accueillait
déjà des occupations humaines au Néolithique.
Le temple y est bien entendu érigé, mais
c’est aussi là qu’a lieu le vote des
citoyens et la démonstration de force des
deux divinités.
C’est en effet cette zone, aujourd’hui
un immense parc archéologique, qui constitue
le cœur de la vie religieuse et civique de
la cité d’Athènes.
Et tout cela pour une très bonne raison qui
saute tout de suite aux yeux:
c’est le site naturel.
L’Acropole, la «ville haute» en grec,
a toutes les caractéristiques géographiques
d’un lieu mythique.
C’est une forteresse naturelle, et les premiers
occupants préhistoriques l'ont tout de suite
compris.
Ses falaises abruptes de plusieurs dizaines
de mètres n'offrent un accès qu’à l’ouest.
Au sommet, 2,5 hectares surplombent la mer
Méditerranée et les plaines de l’Attique…
Tous les ingrédients sont réunis pour un
récit exceptionnel.
Les versions qui nous sont parvenues de cette
histoire, parfois par des voies détournées
diffèrent sur la manière de départager
les dieux.
Soit, le choix est fait par le premier roi
mythique de la ville Cécrops, qui choisit
Athéna mais fait ériger un sanctuaire de
consolation à Poséidon qui accepte sa défaite,
soit il est fait par les citoyens eux-mêmes.
Cette dernière version qui nous vient de
Varron, un écrivain romain du Ier siècle
avant J.-C., comporte une morale un peu différente
puisque c’est par un vote des hommes et
des femmes que le dilemme est résolu.
Les hommes choisissent le cheval et la guerre
tandis que les femmes, majoritaires d’une
seule voix, se rangent du côté de la sagesse
et de la paix.
Pour faire payer cette déconvenue aux Athéniens,
incapables de maîtriser leurs femmes, Poséidon
aurait abattu sur la ville une vague démesurée.
Les Athéniens, effrayés des conséquences
tragiques de cette affaire, auraient alors
privé leurs compagnes du droit de participer
aux affaires de la cité
Ou comment justifier le patriarcat par une histoire alambiquée…
Et puis, Athènes engloutie sous les flots pour avoir bafoué la volonté divine
c'est un peu le mythe de l'Atlantide qui refait surface.
Dans ce mythe, Poséidon perd Athènes mais
gagne l'Atlantide comme lot de consolation.
Pour Platon, Athènes et Atlantide sont liées,
c'est la même cité sous deux identités:
l'une préhistorique et sage, dirigée par
Athéna et l'olivier, l'autre guerrière et
maritime, la cité de Poséidon.
Quand Platon met en garde les Athéniens en
leur rappelant le sort de l'Atlantide engloutie,
il fait aussi référence à cette dispute
originelle et au choix de la sagesse plutôt
qu'à celui de la mer.
Lieu fondateur, le site de l'Acropole continue
d'être aménagé pendant plusieurs siècles.
Des portes monumentales, une réserve d'armes,
et plusieurs temples y sont construits.
Les deux principaux sont dédiés naturellement
à Athéna.
Le premier est le Parthénon, chef-d’œuvre
incontournable et visible de toute la cité
qui montre sur son fronton ouest la dispute
entre Athéna et Poséidon.
Le temple est très richement décoré mais
surtout truffé de détails et nuances conçus
pour tricher avec notre perception.
Légèrement décalé par rapport à l'entrée,
le temple se donne à voir d'emblée sous
son meilleur angle.
Il est pensé pour les yeux avant d'être
pensé pour les dieux.
("sit down miss !")
Le deuxième temple majeur est un édifice
plus discret
et directement lié au mythe de fondation de la ville, l'Erechteion.
D'apparence plus inhabituelle et délicate
que son imposant voisin, l'Erechteion a été
érigé sur les lieux supposés de la dispute
entre les deux divinités.
Il conservait en son sein la statue primitive
d'Athéna, faite de bois et paradoxalement,
plus sacrée et respectée que son immense
réplique faite d'or et d'ivoire siégeant
dans le trésor du Parthénon.
Ce qui fait l'importance du temple ce n'est
pas sa taille, les matériaux employés pour
sa construction ou la quantité et la richesse
des décors, mais bien l'histoire mythique
qui lui est rattachée.
C'est elle qui donne un sens à la pierre,
une histoire de choix et de destin.
Aujourd'hui, le même phénomène existe.
Passer les propylées, les portes monumentales
de l'Acropole, c'est encore faire acte de
pèlerinage.
Le mythe survit, comme toujours, en se transformant.
Athéna n'a plus cours, c'est autre chose
qui se joue ici
une histoire d'images.
Une fois franchi ce seuil, les pèlerins utilisent
ce décor mythique pour mettre en scène leur
propre mythologie.
Couple, famille, aventure, le tout agrémenté
d'une euphorie plus ou moins contenue.
Et c'est finalement le but poursuivi par l'architecte
du Parthénon, Phidias en bâtissant un décor
fait pour la photographie avant même son
invention.
Oublier peut-être Athéna, mais se souvenir
d'Athènes.